I don't even know who the woman let's
say I don't know who it's Marla
okay it's Marla means it's my ex-wife
Marla Maples
there's like Marvel's in this photo
that's Marla yeah that's that's my wife
which one woman are you pointing each
other now here
's carols
and the person the woman on the right is
your then wife I don't know this was the
picture I assume that's John Johnson is
that because it's very blurry I'm not
focusing on the insanity of being
accused of having sexually assaulting
someone and then saying they're not my
type
the right reaction from someone who
doesn't commit sexual assault would be
I've never sexually assaulted anyone and
I I don't sexually assault people anyway
it's not his type except it sort of
seems like she was because he thought it
was his own ex-wife that is wild wild
stuff